so you're the heads of china once one of
the greatest empires in the world
but in the late 1800s and early 1900s
you hit a rough patch
[Music]
china was defeated and pillaged by the
british the french japan
russia basically china an empire that
very much values honor respect was put
to shame on the world stage for over a
hundred years
it was so bad that china would later
call it the century of humiliation
if that wasn't bad enough china also had
a few more rough patches after that with
around 18 to 45
million deaths during a movement they
called the great leap forward
and around another 20 million deaths
during the movement after that called
the cultural revolution
because of all the shame and disgrace
you've grown to resent not just the west
but the rest of the east the north the
south and everyone in between
you long for the days when you were
number one when you were on top of the
world
but don't take my word for it take the
word from all these chinese officials
that regularly spout this
china has become a global leader in
terms of composite national
strength and international influence and
the worst part is that you could easily
be number one if it wasn't for those
milling
americans that believe in democracy
natural rights and other dangerous ideas
like freedom of speech
ideas that if your populist gets a whiff
of it would be the end of your rule
because of these ideas and the fact that
america is the only one standing in your
way for world domination
this automatically makes them public
enemy number one throughout human
history all the way up to the 1900s to
defeat an
enemy state you simply go to war but as
we've seen with our 100 years of shame
traditional warfare hasn't been our
strong suit for a while but it is for
those despicable americans
even though the americans didn't really
win in the middle east or vietnam or
korea their traditional forces of
soldiers tanks and aircraft are a force
to be reckoned with while having
actual combat experience so you put your
pride away and objectively realize that
it's far from guaranteed that you could
win a head-to-head boots on the ground
war with the us
we need a new plan of attack a new way
to wage war where we don't have to go
head first into america's greatest
strength
and our greatest weakness following our
great sun zeus art of war
if you're gonna attack your enemy attack
him where he can't defend
luckily for you times have changed the
modern day battlefield is no longer
fought with bullets but with ones and
zeroes dollars and cents
sure there will always be a time for
conventional warfare but today
instead of storming the desert it's
storming the enemy's walls by attracting
foreign investors money and not letting
that money ever leave your country
instead of killing soldiers it's by
baiting companies that outsource their
workers for dirt cheap labor
thereby taking away jobs from the enemy
country killing their morale and making
them more dependent on you
instead of fighting on the european
front or the pacific front it's fighting
on the economic front the social front
instead of deploying troops it's
deploying cyber warfare troops that sit
behind a computer screen
instead of invading and occupying
smaller nations it's offering them
irresistible loans to build
infrastructure projects
and taking them over once they can't pay
it back war is no longer using force to
compel your enemy to your will but
rather by using
all means armed and unarmed force lethal
and non-lethal force by doing whatever
it takes and you want to know what the
best part is is that while all these
revolutionary changes are happening to
the battlefield
your arch nemesis the u.s are still
spending away all their resources
building up their conventional forces
thinking that they have the most
powerful military
leaving them with no resources are
desired to invest into the real domains
the cyber and economic ones but can you
really blame them the traditional
military industrial complex and defense
contracts make a lot of money
so lucky for us why would they want to
change that's not our job the us
military leaders say
so like everything else their government
does they keep kicking the can down the
road
like sun tzu said if your opponent
doesn't even know they're at war
well they've already lost this is that
strategy
we're at war only
it's not being fought by guns and
missiles not yet at least
it's a war of perception the greatest
long-term threat to our nation's
information and intellectual property
and to our economic vitality is the
counterintelligence and economic
espionage threat
from china that i think it's the most
consequential
existential threat not just to america
just to democracy
the world's ever seen but if you think
these issues
are just an intelligence issue or a
government problem
or a nuisance largely just for big
corporations who can largely take care
of themselves you could not be more
wrong
it's the people of the united states who
are the victims
of what amounts to chinese theft on a
scale so massive
that it represents one of the largest
transfers of wealth
in human history
[Music]
war combat it's all about deception you
make the enemy think you're gonna come
out from one corner to shoot but then
boom
you come out of the other corner and
blow them to bits the modern battlefield
is no different
you make the west believe that you
support free trade and globalization
while systematically taking advantage of
it you tell other countries like the us
to say no to protectionism to tariffs
well that's literally your entire
strategy
you waive the carrot of short-term
profits in front of your enemies that
are drooling at the mouth
while using their money to fund your
rise to number one china
has a fundamentally different system
than ours and it's doing
all it can to exploit the openness of
ours
while taking advantage of its own closed
system
and at the core china's main strategy
and advantage over the us
is just that the ability to think in
decades and centuries instead of
quarterly earnings reports or the next
election cycle
china has a vision a big why a purpose
to guide them through all the short-term
pain in their journey to world
domination with absolute power over
their subjects to back it up
the u.s on the other hand have grown
weak and comfortable from nearly a
hundred years of opulence
and much like how a spoiled child can
never work hard america's prosperity
and freedom will be its own downfall
they're not willing to give up their
comforts to fight a bigger enemy and
their government has hardly any control
over their own citizens
think of china kinda like the old robber
barons like rockefeller or jp morgan but
at a global level
we can use every single dirty trick in
the book to crush
our competitors the chinese government
is engaged in a broad
diverse campaign of theft and malign
influence and it can execute that
campaign
with authoritarian efficiency
they're calculating they're persistent
they're patient and they're not subject
to the righteous constraints of an open
democratic society or the rule of law
every war has different fronts that must
be fought in world war ii it was the
european front and the asia pacific
front
for this new cold war there are many
different fronts where one of the most
important being the economic front
china saw how money turned the u.s into
a global superpower and how
micromanaging everything destroyed the
soviet union
so china took the best of both worlds
they combined the absolute
authoritarianism they needed to stay in
power
but sprinkled on some capitalism to make
the money they would need to dominate
the world
or in other words we realize that money
talks on the global stage so we align
private profit with national interests
china has complete control over the
economy so we can do whatever it takes
to make sure the right companies succeed
in the direction we want and yet we've
created one of the freest environments
to do business
there's no pesky things like the epa
better business bureau intellectual
property rights and yet the government
has the final say on all matters
if they think your company is better
suited merged with this other company
they'll take your company and assets by
force and merge it with the other
an awful lot of large chinese businesses
are state-owned enterprises
literally owned by the government and
thus the party and even if they aren't
china's laws allow its government to
compel
any chinese company to provide any
information it requests
including american citizens data on top
of that
chinese companies of any real size are
legally required
to have communist party cells inside
them to keep them in line
the equivalent to the us government
forcing apple to have a u.s
representative on their board of
directors to make sure everything is
going according to plan
competition among chinese is extremely
dog-eat-dog
and yet important companies get cash
injections and are backed by the
government
because of this close economy we're able
to pull off some very clever tricks that
get us
ever so closer to world domination one
of our greatest tactics is the fact that
when foreign investors put money into
our country
no matter how much money they earn on
paper they can never pull it out of the
here's how it works number one we
attract foreign businesses
investors banks hedge funds many of them
from the us to invest
billions upon billions of dollars over
the years into chinese real estate
businesses stocks
which is not very hard given that we
have the biggest population and the
biggest new market to make money in
number two the investors money is used
to make our economy the fastest growing
in history
while preventing that same money from
being used to grow america's economy
number three the investors see their
money grow on paper which makes them
really happy and attracts more investors
and number four when investors want to
take their earnings out and convert it
into let's say usd
they can't why because this is our
closed economy you have to follow
our rules if you want to play and our
rule is is that we need this money to
stay within our borders to keep funding
our astronomical growth
as long as more money keeps coming into
china unless it's going out
all is going according to plan sure with
the right person applying the right
pressure
money can go out of china but for the
average foreign firm like chevron sony x
on these suckers have had their money
trapped here since 2015.
now if you're sitting there with your
hands stroking your chin wondering
this this kind of sounds like a ponzi
scheme
where investors put money in and their
money is used as returns for the
investor that came in before them
no well i'll let you guys be the judge
of that
and if you think that trick was clever
you have seen nothing yet see every
country's currency's value is determined
by traders on foreign exchange markets
but who says that's how it has to work
if we put our un
on the market we'd completely lose
control over it so the un isn't traded
on foreign exchange markets
everything happens within our borders
its value is whatever we say it is
china has printed 30 trillion dollars
worth of rmb in a decade like
the scale to which they've printed is
again
it's unprecedented can the chinese run
their stock market up
absolutely domestically they control the
price
they control the printing press they
control the police they control the
narrative
and there are many other tricks up our
sleeves forcing foreign companies to
give up the trade secrets to do business
in china when no other nations do that
to chinese firms
stealing anywhere from two to three
trillion dollars worth of intellectual
property from the us over the past 10
years and selling it back to them at a
discount
they all estimate that that number's 200
to 300 billion dollars
worth of ip per year there's a return on
that annually as well
so over the last decade they've stolen
you know two to three trillion
uh in ip from us we've now reached the
point
where the fbi is opening a new
china-related counterintelligence case
about every 10 hours of the nearly 5 000
active fbi counterintelligence cases
currently underway across the country
almost half are all related to china
not allowing western social platforms
like google facebook youtube and our
economy so we can control the narrative
while the west allows all of our
government-controlled social platforms
into their nation so we can influence
their narrative
getting us companies to outsource 3.7
million manufacturing jobs to our very
poor cheap laborers since 2001
pummeling their middle class even more
forcing u.s companies not to spread
ideas we don't like like disney
hollywood the nba
marriott and more all this economic
warfare is for one purpose to fund our
meteoric rise as the fastest growing
economy in history
with everyone else's money while fooling
everyone into thinking that we're
playing by the worlds and that yes you
should definitely keep treating us
fairly even though we're not treating
you fairly
and all this economic power allows us to
move on to the other fronts of this new
cold war
like the all too insidious
infrastructure fronts
infrastructure is one of the most
important aspects of a society
it is literally the underlying
foundation of a country infrastructure
also happens to be one of those things
that is taken for granted by the
populace
people in the u.s typically don't go
about their dates wondering hey
how secure are gas pipelines or
electricity grids or who controls the
shipping ports and container ships where
90
of our goods travel on
[Music]
yet if just one of these systems went
out it would lead to some catastrophic
events
that's why in china we understand just
how important infrastructure warfare is
in our ever more connected world
that's why we have a laser focused on
infrastructure both domestically and
internationally
within china we're focused on making our
economy completely independent from the
outside world where we're not dependent
on exports or imports
an economy that isn't fragile to the
goodwill of others like how every nation
including china is right now
this is where ghost cities come into
play
to create this insulated economy china
started building entire cities
120 in total each designed to hold
between 5 to 10 million people
that's why in just two years from 2012
to 2014
china poured more concrete than the us
did in the last 100 years
because these cities were built ahead of
demand there are 50 ghost cities in
china
50 cities ranging from twice the size of
philadelphia to the size of new york
without a soul to be seen
and guess what china's plan for an
independent super economy was funded by
you guessed it
the west headed by wall street who
probably aren't going to get their money
back
and every cent of this construction went
straight into china's record-breaking
gdp
numbers so that begs the question if
there are 64 million vacant apartments
on the market
and even more vacant business space in
the billions of square feet it would
only make sense that real estate prices
should have already crashed in china
right
well no as we learn in the economic
front china controls the entire economy
including real estate and prices
so we simply prevent this new real
estate from being sold
see what westerners don't understand is
that economic growth is very easy if you
control everything
while we're making our infrastructure
more robust at home
naturally we're focused on making
everyone else's infrastructure more
fragile abroad
this is where the belt and road
initiative or bri comes in
a plan to connect nearly 70 nations many
of them poor desperate emerging nations
around the world
by road rail air and most importantly by
sea
and here's how it works number one find
nations with resources we need whether
that be cheap labor
mined or important locations number two
approach these desperate nations with a
smile and say that in the name of
facilitating free trade and harmony
peace and prosperity
we'll give you a loan that we know you
can't pay back to build infrastructure
projects like a seaport to build up your
economy and will just collect interest
in return a no-brainer deal
you'd be crazy to pass it up and then
boom step number three
once you drown the country in debt it's
basically yours and from here you can do
whatever you want
in the case of the very strategic port
of sri lanka when they couldn't make the
payments they just gave it back to china
with even more land on top of that
in the case of africa you can keep
milking the resources and cementing your
influence and control
as these nations start to prosper you
can sell to them collect their data and
further your influence
and all these locations that are
practically ours are more avenues for us
to send conventional military troops
through
if that time ever comes more on that
later if you want to learn more about
this modern day colonialism
check out our video called the
profitable business of enslaving third
world countries
along with domestic infrastructure and
the bri the last and most important
piece of the infrastructure front
is 5g
[Music]
now if you're looking for 5g conspiracy
theories go watch some other video
because we don't even have to go into
that kind of speculation
5g is not just another phone network
sure it gives consumers up to 100 times
faster speed but for the most part
consumers won't be able to take
advantage of all that extra juice
the real game changer is that this extra
speed and bandwidth will make way for a
new generation of society built around
devices connected to each other
whereas 4g only allows around 6 500
devices per square mile
5g can support up to a million devices
per square mile
this extra capacity means that every
aspect of a society's infrastructure
planes trains machinery self-driving
cars smart homes connected healthcare
agriculture cameras the military will be
able to communicate with each other over
a 5g network
more data being collected means that
more data can be funneled into ai and
machine learning algorithms at an even
faster rate
and if you thought technology was
already moving fast if the highway data
travels on gets supercharged
the pace of technology will increase at
an even more incomprehensible rates
we already talked about how fragile
nations are to the infrastructure
so if the future of infrastructure is
powered over 5g networks
if one were to control said 5g networks
one could theoretically have the keys
not to just the kingdom
but to the entire modern world including
all of one's enemies
in our modern world there is perhaps no
more ominous prospect
than a hostile foreign government's
ability to compromise
our country's infrastructures and
devices
if one controlled all 5g networks one
could theoretically view all the world's
data traveling on those super highways
including business plans military plans
academic papers
engineering plans surveillance camera
feeds anything and everything sent over
5g
one could also turn off aspects of a
nation's infrastructure at will
one could collect and feed everyone's
data into one's own ai algorithms like
one is already doing with the government
controlled social media platforms
or in other words if china is gonna get
back to its glory days on the world
stage
it would be very advantageous of us to
take the same approach we're doing with
the belt and road initiative
generously offered to build a 5g
networks for other nations
out of our own goodwill of course but
you gotta keep this part extra secret
because other countries are starting to
catch on to our intentions
like japan australia and the uk india
those middling americans of course and
maybe even the eu if we don't act fast
if chinese companies like huawei are
given unfettered access
to our telecommunications infrastructure
they could collect any of your
information
that traverses their devices or networks
worse still they'd have no choice but to
hand it over to the chinese government
if asked the privacy and due process
protections that are sacrosanct
in the united states are simply
non-existent
in china there are many other fronts in
this new cold war that we don't have
time to get into
the cyber warfare front the technology
front the social front but there's one
more friend worth mentioning an
under the radar return to the
conventional military fronts
as we mentioned in the beginning of this
video as long as we're not guaranteed to
win the conventional war with the us
we'll keep fighting on the more subtle
modern day battlefield but china
isn't dumb we know that conventional
warfare will never go away and that
someday
we might just have to participate in it
and as the west has been funding our
rise we've been investing a lot of that
money not just a normal infrastructure
like we already talked about
but also into our military so if or when
that time ever comes
we can strike china already has more
warships than the u.s navy while the u.s
has been lowering its icbm count due to
international agreements
we've been stockpiling hours and
regularly show them off
and a healthy amount of us military
components and raw materials come
straight from china
the propellant that fires their missiles
materials for their night vision goggles
their entire telecom system their
computers they're entirely dependent on
us
so for now we'll just keep selling war
materials to the americans
build up our own power and control and
then strike if the time comes
so you know that war is all about
deception not just conventional fighting
you know about our economic front the
business front all the different
infrastructure fronts at home and abroad
and how we're gearing up our
conventional fronts
so the question remains who's gonna win
this new cold war
well if the west keeps fighting each
other about systematic racism while the
concept of racial discrimination doesn't
even exist in china with this very own
concentration
camps and cattle cars mind you if the
west keeps calling a certain president a
tyrant when there's an actual
authoritarian regime a few thousand
miles off the coast of california that
makes the certain president look like
gandhi
if consumers keep buying chinese plastic
just to save a buck
well they better start learning mandarin
and let's just calm down and put this
[Music]
okay confronting this threat effectively
does not mean we shouldn't do business
with the chinese
does not mean we shouldn't host chinese
visitors it does not mean we shouldn't
welcome chinese students or co-exist
with china on the world stage but it
does mean
that when china violates our criminal
laws and international norms we are not
going to tolerate it
much less enable it the fbi and our
partners throughout the u.s government
will hold china accountable
and protect our nation's innovation
ideas
and way of life with the help and
vigilance
of the american people thank you for
having me here today
speaking of learning mandarin check out
today's video sponsor
um i mean we don't have a sponsor
because not many brands are willing to
support this video
economic warfare at its finest so i tell
you what if you want to support this
channel financially and you want more
videos like this one
check out a course i made on how to land
a remote job this is how i got my start
and this whole make money online thing
with a 40
per hour remote web dev job and i
believe it's the most practical way for
others to get started as well
you don't have to start a business from
scratch you learn valuable skills on
your own time while making consistent
money so you're not starving to death
and as we've seen in recent times remote
jobs are a lot less fragile than
traditional ones
and my favorite part is that you can use
remote jobs as a jumping off point for
whatever you want
you can use the extra time to work on a
side business like i did or you can be a
digital nomad traveling the world which
a lot of people do with their remote
jobs as well
and with this course it walks you
through what jobs to go after based on
your personality what the best route to
learn it are
standing out when applying to jobs and
interviews and basically everything you
need from start to finish
and you can start your remote journey
right now for a very reasonable price
and support this channel at the same
time with the link below
gentle reminder that i have partnered up
with the chinese communist party and for
every single time you guys watch a video
leave a comment leave a like subscribe
turn on the notification bell
your social credit score will go up by
one point so get that social credit
score up before you get thrown into a
concentration camp i mean a re-education
gap
nobody here is a criminal no sir okay
gentlemen sorry we couldn't work
anything out but uh
i'm gonna go home and pay my taxes
highly highly recommend you guys read
the book that this video is based on
called stuff for
how china took over while america's
elite slept by brigader general robert
spalding from what i understand brigader
general is like one of the highest ranks
in the military so this guy
he knows what he's talking about it's
not that long or a hard read and it goes
over like a ton of stuff that i didn't
have time to cover in this video also i
see you guys backing me up in the
warzone that is the comment section this
is turning out to be like a real mafia
where you like defend the godfather so
you know
don tran really appreciates it and i
want you to know that i see you
and i really appreciate you
all right you can follow me on instagram
at jaketrend.io for like behind the
scenes stuff uh
teasers random memes me ranting about
stuff
it's pretty good over there so join us
over at instagram jaketrend.io
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous i'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you